[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world in pop
culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Bruce and I'm Ayano ade and
this is your news for Monday January
15th first up this week we saw an
awesome new trailer for the movie Bravin
starring Jason MoMA and it's about a
family who somehow gets caught up in a
drug smuggling gone wrong the drug
smugglers have to hide that drugs in
their cabin that they keep for the
winter and as they go to close it up for
the winter uh-oh drug dudes come back
they find like satchels of drugs just
like sitting in the cabin so of course
Jason mama has to protect his family
those arrows it looks really cool
actually and it looks like his daughter
kind of like hijacks her way on until
then all of a sudden they see these drug
guys and she's like daddy
you're like it looks super action-packed
now and actually very cool yes so we can
check that out on February 2nd yeah
which is fairly soon so it's kind of
interesting that this is the one of the
first trailers we've gotten for it and
coming out in a couple of weeks that's
right so I'm definitely gonna be
checking that out and also coming out
soon on HBO is the new series mosaic now
you can actually check out the whole
series right now on their app which I
actually have and it's super cool the
idea on this app is that you can watch
all the content but it's sort of choose
your own adventure style so you can
decide whose storyline you want to see
you can go back and watch other stuff of
course as well but as you progress you
kind of see it very one-sided if you
choose and the ending doesn't
necessarily change but your idea of the
ending
could possibly have some rain with the
case
as you go clicking to see whodunit
exactly and you get to like play
detectives because some of the things
that you unlock watching each episode
and each episode is different in length
on the app as well it's not just a set
you watch a 20 minute episode some of
them are more like 40 minutes some of
them are 17 and as you go you unlock
little extras so you can unlock more of
that person's like flow in the storyline
progression or you can occasionally
unlock document so you open up a PDF and
it tells you about this and stuff like
that and it's really cool you get to
just go play detective on this whole
series I will say the one downside is I
watching it on a phone it's it's very
much found lighting or natural lighting
and so it can be occasionally very dark
so you can't really watch it outside or
while you're traveling it also it takes
up a lot of Wi-Fi so you probably don't
want to use up your data anyways right
but if you're watching it at home it's
kind of weird holding your phone for 40
minutes if you know yeah yeah so I will
say that's kind of a downside but fear
not because you don't have to do any of
that you can wait for January 22nd the
whole series is going to be out on HBO
but they get to choose the adventure
okay yeah I was gonna say it'll be
really interesting to see how they
translate then right choose your own
adventure app and so it's gonna be very
much straightforward and they're going
to have it edited in the perspective
that they want to see you at certain
times there might be extra footage that
we haven't seen but for the most part
it's going to be pretty much the same
footage but they're just going to choose
it for you in a very like in their own
linear' way okay yeah yeah so I'm very
excited to see if there's any interest
is differences on HBO otherwise you can
check it all out on the app right no
like I have it's pretty cool it's pretty
fun playing detective
she's been pretty obsessed is really
cool I basically figured out who the
killer is
oh the right be a murderer it's a thief
I got like a murder mystery but no
spoilers this week also we
heard that John wick is getting its own
TV show spit off on stars it's gonna be
called the Continental so it'll be based
around the sweet hotel and man how much
am I gonna love delving into that one
because that's some really cool world
building and it's got to be
action-packed right now waiting for me
hopefully we're gonna see some canneries
like guest appearances maybe a few
cameos if you're lucky because he is
co-producing it with Chad Starsky who
also did the genre films as well yeah
and then the showrunner is Chris Collins
so we've got some cool stuff on the
horizon for a John wick show I think
there's so much like world that's
already built in the movies I would love
to see more yeah and I mean I know they
said that it's going to be a very
similar tone yeah to the movie and
they're gonna try to fit in as much
action as they can but the thing that I
thought was interesting is I believe
they made a statement saying that what
they would like to do is focus more on
making great action sequences and maybe
less of them so that the quality is
there instead of the quantity which I
can get behind
absolutely let's have some high quality
action our John wick but that's right
I mean if daredevil can pull off some
pretty sweet fight sequences in a show I
mean there's a few shows like that but
John wick the movie has some pretty good
ones and it's pretty much just chocked
full of them so if we get a few lesson
in TV show and end up learning some more
about different characters or different
things about the world I'm fine just
make them some great fight sequences
this week we heard some news on
something that we weren't quite sure
what's gonna happen and that is the
Black Widow movie it's maybe happening
but they may still maybe when they
finally got a writer for a script so
there can at least be a script there's
been talks about making a movie for
Black Widow forever this is a long time
coming everyone so it is a huge sigh of
relief almost that we finally have a
writer attached to this project and the
writer is Jack Schaeffer who
has written nasty women which is a
female adaptation of dirty rotten
scoundrels which is going to come out
this year later this year and then we
also found out that she wrote the Olaf's
frozen adventure but I'm just excited to
see that they do have a female writer
attached to the project so she'll be
able to bring that angle to the project
into production it's about time about
time you know but also still just a
maybe any casting or anything more than
that great exactly
gotta get a script first and at least
it's a step forward so I'll take it yes
a step forward also sign up a female
director for that yeah yeah I mean
Scarlett Johansson I'm sure would be
right on board with that 100% sure sure
so hopefully we'll get more news coming
soon about that and maybe even can we
can we have one made one Marvel in other
movie news this week the Channing Tatum
gambit movie has lost its third director
that's right director number four is
what they're looking for right now so
it's already got a script and a cast and
a release dates but no director yeah yep
they had a director attached and then he
left due to scheduling conflicts it was
Gore Verbinski yes yes yes yeah so just
have fun
considering this is director number
three I'm wondering if it's a little bit
more than some scheduling issues that's
going on with this movie
maybe maybe and because of that then
they also had to push back the release
date we reported oh my gosh probably
months ago yeah that they had set a
release date for Valentine's Day of 2019
so now because they're still searched
for director number four it's been
pushed back to June 7th which completely
makes sense if they haven't even started
filming or anything like that or still
looking for a director well we'll see
what happens with that aisle happening a
band well rumor is they're gonna try to
at least get it out there before the
Disney Fox merger if that's going to go
through so that they can still have that
released before that happens so they're
still trying to as fast as they can get
a director to get that to happen Fox
also announced this week that they're
changing the release dates of the two
other mutant movies that are happening
Deadpool 2 that Deadpool 2 is actually
getting moved up so initially it was
supposed to be June and now it's going
to be May 18th and one of the reasons
that they have done this is because if
they don't want it to compete with the
new Han Solo movie so they want it to
come out the week before the Han Solo
movie so that they don't have to worry
about people going to see Han Solo movie
rather than Deadpool 2 but honestly
given the choice I would see Deadpool 2
anyway about the Han Solo movie which at
least is having its first trailer
dropped sometime today tonight that's
right I'm sure we're good to finally see
the state of that affair I'm so
interested it's just interested to see
if it's gonna be a train wreck or not
that's right I don't know and we'll see
they still don't necessarily know just
from the trailer right also true and
then they also announced that New
Mutants is pushing back its release date
initially it was supposed to be April
13th of this year like in a couple of
months here I thought it was all done
and they were ready to go we saw a
trailer for it but
now it's not going to be released until
February 22nd of 2019 right and they say
that it's because they want to give it
breathing room since Deadpool is coming
out in May they want to give it its own
time to breathe and also they said it's
not scary enough they were concerned
that since this is their first adventure
into a mutants horror film they wanted
to make sure that it was going to be
scary scary scary so I'm hoping that
doesn't mean that we're gonna get some
really awkward studio mandated reshoots
that are going to kind of weaken it
rather than strengthen it get on top of
those wigs people we've already been
there with a on top of those haircuts
yeah so well I'm so looking forward to
New Mutants it sounds kind of entry
sounds different and I am embracing the
difference so yeah I think that's gonna
be it from us here guys there's so much
more that happened this week talk to us
in the comments down below as to what we
missed and what to look forward to we're
gonna be taking a couple weeks off here
a tour of a report from the holidays
it's been a busy time but we'll be back
with you in February otherwise you can
get us at on social media Heather where
is that for you on Twitter you can find
me at how the roof's Instagram at a
truce or twitch twitch TV slash Heather
ruse and you can find me on Facebook as
I anna-wade or everywhere else as
awesome
Ayana we will see you in a few weeks in
the meantime you be what's up
[Applause]
you